hey everyone welcome welcome welcome in
to another edition of Market takes it is
a beautiful day to dissect some economic
data the sun is shining the birds are
chirping I don't know you could have
been anywhere in the world but you are
here with me and I appreciate that I am
Dion rabone reporter at the Wall Street
Journal today we are diving into
unpacking explaining the CPI consumer
price index report CPI just came out
this morning uh the markets are having a
reaction in a pretty big way I think the
reaction we've seen especially on the
stock prices uh from the stock markets
and from Commodities has been very
interesting so we're going to get into
what all that was and why all that was
here in just a sec but of course we're
going to talk about what the CPI report
said break down what those headline
numbers were as well as get under the
surface and explain how those numbers
compared to expectations uh we're also
going to talk about the biggest takeaway
I think there's one big takeaway you can
get from today's report in terms of
looking at all the other data that we've
seen we're of course going to talk about
the how this report changes or moves
expectations for what we think the
Federal Reserve is going to do next or
at least what investors think the
Federal Reserve is going to do next
we're going to take a look at the
markets like I said we're going to talk
stocks bonds Commodities we're going to
talk a little bit about those currency
markets as well so stay tuned for that
and we're going to explain what today's
report tells us about the future and
what to look for next so without further
Ado let's get into it the CPI report
today showed 4.9 percent year-over-year
inflation in April as well as a 0.4
increase in inflation month over month
so as you look here this is the year
over year chart that we've got up here
right now on your screen and you can see
we've seen inflation consistently come
down since that peak in June when
inflation at nine percent it's been
coming down and this month we had 4.9
percent last month it was five percent
the month before that it was six going
all the way back up and you see that
consistent downturn in CPI inflation and
you see it's been coming down that
that's what the market wants to see
that's what the Federal Reserve wants to
see and this had been right along with
expectations for five percent year over
year a little bit below that at 4.9 0.4
month over month right over the right on
the numbers now I want to put this other
chart up here on your screen and that is
the core Consumer Price Index that's
when you strip out food and energy
prices which are very volatile so the
FED likes to see okay what's happening
at the core of the market or of the of
the economy right now with inflation and
as you look you see those numbers not
quite moving along the same trajectory
you see a consistent downturn since June
in terms of the numbers moving lower but
then the last few months we saw a pickup
last month core inflation actually Rose
to 5.6 percent year over year last month
and this month coming in or sorry in
April coming in at 5.5 percent so core
inflation being a bit more stubborn than
the overall inflation in terms of coming
down and that's maybe got some folks on
the market side worry so we're got from
some folks on the market side a little
worried I should say and this
illustrating that Trend that we have
seen overall in markets so what we've
got is the core CPI when you take out
shelter core CPI Services X shelter
that's the super core metric that also
decreased to 0.266 month over month down
from 0.294 month over month last month
uh all those numbers mean is that the
feds what the FED has said is the most
important thing to watch now core super
core inflation or super core CPI
inflation it's a mouthful
um what the FED has said to watch that
super core number has been coming down
while overall inflation's coming down
core coming down just a little bit at
the margins but coming down everything
kind of moving in the right direction
the direction the FED wants to see it in
that's got markets a little bit excited
now when we talk about what's moving up
and what's moving down in this report
because not everything moves in the same
direction as the overall Index right so
we saw transportation services down
month over month medical care services
down month over month so overall the
services reading on the CPI number moved
lower but it's still up year over year
so month over month the trend is coming
down but year over year we see we are
still up and still higher I want to get
into the the context the nuts and bolts
just a little bit more I want to read
you a quote from Goldman Sachs Asset
Management this morning they said quote
the below five percent headline CPI
number is a sigh of relief to a market
on edge the data today will be
interpreted as not hot enough to force
the fed's hand in June the FED has an
excuse now not to hike in fact the
Market's first reaction to is to price
that the FED will be done and I think
we're seeing that in markets going to
talk about that in just a second so
listen one thing I saw I saw a very
interesting quote in my inbox this
morning it said this report confirms CPI
is trending as expected what does that
mean well that's bullish that means the
markets there's not a new worry
introduced to the markets there's not
you know anything that's oh goodness now
we got to worry about inflation picking
back up or moving in a direction we
didn't expect Market is pricing that
inflation is going to get back down
towards or close to the fed's two
percent Target by the end of the year
that's been priced and that's what
you're seeing in the stock market in the
bond market is expectations for that to
happen so for this report to come in as
expected you are seeing a continuation
of those themes what's driving inflation
we saw a huge jump in used car prices up
4.4 percent over the month um 4.4 month
over month is a big huge number and we
know how much used car prices moved uh
the CPI figures last year and coming
into the start of well actually really
at the end of 2021 and into 2022 and
then that has started to fade away so
used car prices have not been as much of
an increase or a push up on overall
inflation we saw a big jump in that
number the index for shelter was the
largest contributor to the monthly all
items increase this is straight from the
bls's report followed by increases in
the index for used cars and trucks and
the index for gasoline so we know that
all of those things if we look at the
real-time indicators and if we look at
the consistent Trends have been moving
lower so the fact they picked up one
month well the Market's saying okay that
may be a one month aberration that might
just be happening this month we don't
think that's going to continue and so
that's again good news for this overall
inflation theme now if we see uh
gasoline prices continue to pick up if
we see used car prices continue to pick
up that might be worrisome for the
market because these are worries that we
thought we were done with that we
thought oh yeah that's in the past and
so investors are really kind of looking
past those increases and saying overall
this is a good thing now a big piece of
this could be the index for gasoline the
increase in the gasoline index more than
offset declines in other energy
component indexes and the energy index
overall Rose 0.6 six percent all that
means is that overall you've got energy
picking up even though fuel oil natural
gas things like that declined diesel
overall gasoline prices increased what
we're seeing at the pump is rising and
that has a big impact on consumer psyche
folks when they see those prices rising
at the pump they think oh man inflation
might be coming back prices are going to
rise I need to demand more at work I
need to try and get a raise because I've
got to keep up with these overall
inflation prices I was just in Phoenix
recently saw gas prices over five
dollars a gallon uh just a couple weeks
ago in Phoenix the U.S average is 353
3.53 cents a gallon versus 360 a month
ago versus 437 years a year ago so again
Trend moving in the right direction but
it's a it remains to be seen whether
that will continue
we've also got the food index being
unchanged we know that food has been a
big consistent part of this overall
inflation story food was unchanged in
April again it was unchanged in March as
well index for food at home uh declining
that had been something that had been
really spiking up what you're paying at
the grocery store had been picking up on
a big on a big level that's going down
this month well the index for food away
from home Rose point four percent index
for airline fares the index for new
vehicles were among those that decrease
so airline price is getting a little bit
cheaper that's good to see as we
approach those summer flying months when
a lot of Americans do traveling
um listen one thing that we don't want
to forget and one thing that I pointed
out in our look ahead earlier this week
was corporate profits corporate profit
margins in are on Pace to increase for
the first quarter once we get all those
earnings reports we will know whether
corporate profits picked up and increase
again right now it looks like they will
and that was a huge driver in fact the
main driver of overall inflation
increases that we saw last year here
that led to that big nine percent
increase year over year we are seeing
right now S P net profit margins which
means the amount of profit that
companies are making for every dollar of
sales increase it's on Pace to rise to
the first quarter in six quarters it
decreased six straight quarters and now
it's expected to increase uh if we
continue on this trajectory it's up 11.5
percent
um from what it was a year ago now keep
in mind that corporate profit number
corporate net profit margins up 11 and a
half percent that compares to 4.9 prop
4.9 overall inflation and 2.7 percent
increase in producer prices AKA
wholesale prices or what companies are
paying so companies prices are
increasing at about 2.7 percent and
their net profit marches are increasing
eleven and a half percent that puts more
upward pressure on inflation that's
something you're going to want to keep
an eye on is the role that company
profits play in inflation the Oil Pro
oil companies as well have seen big
profit margin gains and that could be
part of why prices at the pump are still
high even though overall oil prices have
declined pretty significantly keep your
eye on that and that's why you want to
watch out for those reports those
earnings reports from oil companies
because even though oil prices are
declining coming down from their highs
oil companies are just keeping prices
High keeping that difference as profit
so let's take a step back now and talk
about expectations for the Federal
Reserve the market very clearly after
this report came out was betting the
Federal Reserve is going to pause at its
June meeting and then start cutting
rates again soon and an interesting
development in the FED fund's Futures
markets uh we're seeing an increased
increasing bets on a rate cut in July
folks had really been betting the Fed
was going to start cutting rates in
September and that was sort of the move
that was priced in but after this CPI
report came out we saw a move in fed
fund's Futures prices showing a 36
percent likelihood of a cut in July all
that means is that folks think that okay
with inflation slowing down even though
it's still more than double the fed's
two percent target folks are betting
that in just a couple months we could
see a Fed rate cut as soon as July 36
percent chance of that and if you go out
to September you're seeing a rate a rate
cut fully priced in with a 22 chance of
two rate Cuts as soon as September what
a 50 basis point rate cut basically the
FED cutting the equivalent of two rate
Cuts or maybe cutting in July and again
in September that is big for the market
because it not only signifies that folks
don't believe what the FED says remember
the Federal Reserve Fed chair Jerome
Palace said we are not cutting rates we
are going to keep rates elevated even
though we may be pausing for right now
we are going to keep rates at this high
level through the end of the year or
maybe even raise them if inflation
starts to pick back up the Market's
saying not only do we not believe you we
think you're going to start cutting and
we think you're going to start cutting
soon that the rubber is going to meet
the road here very quickly the FED if
they're going to cut in July is going to
have to signal that in June that could
we could see some big Market moves in
June or in July so watch that watch this
space as I like to say
um that is holding stock prices up
because folks expect okay companies are
having a tough time now but we think
that things are going to change pretty
soon and that could push those stock
prices up so we're not going to sell
we're not going to get out of stocks
it's also pushing those bond yields down
making it cheaper for companies to
borrow money
um want to throw one more chart up here
on your screen and this is going to show
the difference between what we're
looking at in terms of big companies
versus small companies this is the net
percentage of U.S banks tightening
lending standards what that means is
what percentage of banks in the FED
study are making it harder for you to
get a loan making it harder to give
businesses loans whether the small
businesses this is more mid-size and
large companies but how tough is it to
get a loan are you requiring higher
credit scores you require more
collateral are you requiring a longer
relationship and this right here is
showing 46 percent of banks are
increasing those lending standards
making it harder for folks to get a loan
harder for businesses to get a loan and
we know that this affects smaller
companies more than bigger companies so
while while conditions have been easier
for large companies that can issue stock
or issue bonds out on Capital markets
conditions have gotten significantly
Tighter and more difficult to get money
for these small businesses and as we can
see it we've already risen into
recession level conditions when it comes
to the net percentage of U.S Bank's
tightening lending standards whenever
it's gotten this tight before as you see
they're on your screen we have had a
recession so keep your eye on that but
also it's interesting to note that we
didn't get a big pickup this last we we
just have the reporting period in from
April um and we didn't get a big pickup
between April and January as we're
expecting after Silicon Valley Bank
collapsed after first Republic and all
that so we didn't get a big pick up
there so that just illustrates like I
said that it's harder right now for
companies to borrow money especially the
smaller ones but not getting a lot
harder as a lot of folks would expect it
as a lot of folks would have expected
now let's talk about and let's take a
look at what's going on in the markets I
want to put up here on your screen what
we're seeing overall in the stock market
the bond market now initially when that
CPI report came out you saw stocks open
up higher and this is the Dow Jones
Industrial Average right now and then as
folks kind of digested you saw these
stock prices really drop and even went
negative and we are back up positive now
just a little bit the Dow is up about
0.1 percent the NASDAQ up 1.13 I want to
show you just for for context here the
five day chart uh and you see right here
boom just a big take off this morning
and that really all came after that CPI
report was released so you see a big
pickup especially on the NASDAQ because
the NASDAQ has those Tech names that are
much more impacted by the federal
reserve's rate hiking uh cycle and we
have seen those pick up significantly
stocks are way up for the NASDAQ you see
up one percent versus half percent for
the s p and just a little bit over 0.1
percent on the Dow when we look out here
at the bond prices
we're seeing the 30-year down a little
bit but want to take you into the yields
that are much more impacted by fed
expectations the two-year note you see a
huge drop and that comes right after 8
30 when we got that CPI report bond
yields going down which means price is
going up basically folks saying I want
to buy bonds because I think yields are
going to be lower I think the FED is
going to cut rates I think that
inflation is going to keep coming down
and that just illustrating overall what
we've seen from the markets on that side
of things you also saw similar things
happening with oil prices with copper
prices gold actually had picked up
initially after the CPI report came out
and then came back down so that was what
we had seen from markets in reaction to
the data we got this morning listen big
step back what are we looking at the
effect on the current narrative is folks
are expecting that the economy will get
a little rough the FED will cut rates
and that will be good for especially
risky stock prices and risky assets like
things like oil we expect rate Cuts is
what the market is saying as soon as
July pricing goes in a little bit sooner
than September but there is no doubt
right now in the market the market is
has a zero percent likelihood right now
that by December the FED will have rates
where it has them right now that's and I
said I'll say it again zero percent
likelihood is what the market is seeing
as the FED keeping rates at its level
right now Market is pricing in at least
three cuts from the fed by December and
there are some expectations now for four
rate Cuts that's big
um what's next well we've got more data
coming out this week PPI the producer
price index will be out um on Thursday
that's coming up tomorrow and again that
report showing 2.7 percent increase year
over year for producers so that is just
really come down significantly and
moving towards the fed's target for CPI
2.2 percent now that's important because
we have seen for a long time PPI lead
CPI so you're going to want to watch
that we also get the Empire State
manufacturing report on Monday that
usually is not highly watched but those
numbers have been so bad over the course
of this year every report we've seen
from fed manufacturing survey has just
been bad negative if not negative by 10
20 points it's been at least on the
below zero side so watch out for that
one on on Monday if we get another very
negative print it could be an ominous
sign for the overall state of
manufacturing maybe for recession
expectations we will be talking right
here on Monday Market takes we'll give
you your look ahead and next week we've
got U.S retail sales on Tuesday we'll be
talking about all that listen I'm your
host Dion rabone reporter at the Wall
Street Journal this has been Market
takes I thank you so much for being with
us and I hope you'll be with us again
next time